fiery twists brutal violence and high
stakes drama give viewers glued to their
screens but how much of Griselda is real
the real life drug Lord's son says there
were some serious mistakes since
arriving on January 25th Griselda has
dominated on Netflix enticing casual
subscribers and crime drama enthusiasts
alike to give it a try the series
spotlights Colombian drug lord Grisel de
Blanco portrayed by longtime Modern
Family favorite Sophia arara as she
builds an immensely powerful and
financially lucrative cartel it's a
story full of twists turns tension and
more that hasn't gone on notice by the
real griselda's family in fact her only
surviving son Michael Corleone Blanco
watched the show and he made it known
how he felt about the whole thing during
an appearance on the real Griselda
hosted by Billy Corbin he said I feel
that the story our story my family's
story The Blanco family's Universe it's
so complex and so legendary it should be
shown respect when it comes to
storytelling I think the story U
deserved a little more Blanco also found
Griselda to be a surreal viewing
experience and something of an emotional
roller coaster I found myself gasping
for air I found myself happy I found
myself sad and with all of that said
Blanco found that Griselda leaves a lot
to be desired in terms of historical
accuracy right off the bat naturally
when any film or television show aims to
bring real world people and events to
General audiences the question of
historical accuracy always arises
according to Michael Corleone Gisela
doesn't quite translate his mother's
life to the small screen Faithfully
speaking on the first episode lady comes
to town where viewers Griselda attempt
to sell a single kilo of cocaine in 1978
Miami loo called the serious deviation
from reality quite embarrassing he
explained the lady was the number one
cocaine distributor in the world by 1975
she created the industry that means
selling cocaine in 1978 wasn't much
trouble for the real Griselda lanco
further detailed that his mother was far
from helpless in her chosen line of work
during the period in which the episode
takes place nobody had Laboratories she
pioneered the routes she pioneered
everything of the modern-day COC
industry as we know it that paints a
much different picture of Griselda than
the one presented in the first episode
of the Netflix miniseries despite those
issues he clarified that Griselda does
find its footing in the historical
accuracy Department through one key area
before her assassination at the age of
69 on September 3rd 2012 giselda Blanco
had four sons all of them feature
throughout giselda often spending time
alongside their mother as she goes about
maintaining her drug Empire though he
made it abundantly clear that the
Netflix effort is far from historically
accurate overall Michael Le only stated
that the series excels in its depictions
of griselda's Dynamics with her children
when asked by Billy Corbin about the
most accurate elements of Griselda
episode one Blanco brought up his
mother's bond with her children and how
well it's presented amid the crime drama
of it all I liked that wherever my
mother went we went with her so I like
the fact that they tried to humanize the
character that was nice that's probably
it one of you can sleep in the chair
that sorry long flight unfortunately he
then reiterated that the episode
otherwise almost complet failed to
recount that portion of his mother's
tale accurately oh well true or not
there's no denying that audiences are
enamored with a thrilling drama all six
episodes of Griselda are now streaming
on
Netflix